welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy that calls a
girl nightwing
because she's what my dick turns into
dick grayson i mean by that
so yes we're still a family-friendly
show now the batman is just
under a year away but that doesn't mean
that the marketing for the film
isn't in full effect we have a whole
host of new promo images and posters
that drop today
which sure things like the riddler
batman and a lot more we're going to be
breaking it all down in this video
and pointing out some of the cool
details in them as well as giving our
theories on what they mean for the film
now if you enjoy the video then please
smash the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for a sweet
serving of justice every single day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our batman image
breakdown
riddle me this which fun and friendly
villain
looks like an absolute psychopath now
yes it's the riddler i know we all had a
bad
2020 but this guy has turned from a
lovable clown
into one of the most terrifying comic
book villains ever made
when the trailer for the film first
dropped a lot of people were shocked to
see that the riddler was heavily based
on descriptions of the zodiac killer
and we now have a brand new close-up of
the character
i originally had a low-res version of
this image sent to me a couple of weeks
ago in black and white
whether this has been colorized by a fan
or not i don't know
but it looks absolutely incredible
warner bros have been clamping down on
leaks for a long time
hence why i didn't post anything about
it but i've been absolutely dying to
talk to everyone about this image
now i know from sources working on the
film that this will be how the character
looks for the majority of the movie
when the trailer first dropped many
theorized that he would be donning this
for the start of the film
however reeves is trying to keep things
as grounded as possible
so he won't be appearing in spandex or
really changing from this
from what i've been told vance also
theorized that there was duct tape
wrapped around his face
but this image clearly shows that he's
wearing a mask
rather than being someone that would
have to remove his eyebrows
every time he took it off i wonder who
the riddler is
hey batman have you tried this guy haha
yeah
great great jokes at the channel uh
there's also a green question mark in
the middle of a target
and this just looks so raw it's like the
logo of a metal band from the 90s
and i'm so hyped to see if this is used
in the movie on clues
now why i think it might not be is
because there was also a post to what
looks like a puzzle with the pieces
placed slightly wrongly together that's
terrible grammar but
i am the world's greatest detective and
if you look closely mate yeah
just look closely and you might actually
see that yeah these pieces
all slot together to make a green
question mark see
that's why i'm the best breakdowns on
the net now the text
also reads to the batman my life has
been a cruel riddle
it's very puzzling and enigmatic and i
hope we get an
origin story where the character is bit
by a radioactive riddle
i'm really curious to know what this
means as there could be a number of
things taken from it
but we do know that in the film he will
be called edward nashton
in the comics we of course know that
he's called edward nigma
so perhaps the character was an orphan
and he's trying to find out who his real
parents
are this would mean that his life is
somewhat of a mystery
a riddle if you will and it could entail
that he discovers his true name is
mystery enigma
by the end of the film next up are
several shots of the batman
and in the first one the dude looks
badass we can see some twilight shining
in that will make you completely forget
rob battenson was once in those vampire
movies
and it perfectly captures the character
it's very haunting
and such an incredible shot i'm guessing
that this is in the cave
but even if it's just purely for
promotion it definitely highlights that
the batman lives his life in the shadows
we also have a follow-up one of batman
in the rain
this looks absolutely incredible and it
perfectly sets the tone for what this
movie is gonna be
it looks dark and gritty as hell and
like it's been ripped straight out of
the pages
of dc's black label collection the tone
really comes across in this shot
and i feel that it's very very epic we
also have one that accompanied these of
batman holding a batarang
this is something i too got sent a
couple of weeks ago and it's been used
on hot wheels toyota
and will probably be popping up on a lot
of the promotional material
the batarang itself looks almost
identical to the logo that is being used
for the film
and as i always say batman has a good
understanding
when it comes to branding lastly out of
the batman bunch is this amazing poster
that's gonna become my phone wallpaper
in the next 15 seconds
looks incredible and it has the city of
gotham superimposed onto batman
with him looking over the top of it with
the moon behind him
there's also of course the batmobile
riding out in front
but there are some cool details that you
might not have noticed
the skyscraper that we can see in the
middle is actually the chicago tribune
tower
why this is important is because
recently we actually got some behind the
scenes images
of the new movie flying fox man who is
jumping from it
however viewers look closely that isn't
actually flying
fox man it's really batman and i'm
guessing that this is actually wayne
tower and that the character will be
using this as a base of operations to
look over the city
from here he will be able to jump from
it and glide to almost any location
and with it being central to the city
it's the perfect place for batman to
operate out of
this is a really cool poster and i can't
wait to hang it up in my room so i can
impress
all the girls that i always bring round
now speaking of girls
next is the catwoman who we can see
still wearing the balaclava mask with
the little ears pointing out of it
similar to the riddler
i've been told that she will remain in
this get up for the majority of the
proceedings
and it'll only be later on in the movie
that things really start to change
now we do know that she is the daughter
of mob boss falcone
and in the comic that this is based upon
the long halloween the character
searches for the identity of her parents
she ends up coming face to face with the
batman in falcone's penthouse
and the pair fight one another this
seems very similar to shots in the
trailer
so i'm guessing that a similar plot will
play out here with her being on the
search for who her real dad is
however the pair did appear together at
the funeral so maybe she already knows
and is trying to bring her father down
this aesthetic has been seen in several
batman properties
such as the mystery of the batwoman so
potentially they brought across the plot
points from that
for this movie we also have quite a low
res one of her on a bike
which we of course know batman chases
her on in the movie
careful bruce looks like you've falling
for it
you've got your sucker i want a side
tangent someone actually said that this
stunt man might have fallen on purpose
and this could be why selena gets away
this shot might even be in the movie and
i might have been taking the mick out of
it for the last year
when really the stunt man was meant to
do it so yeah
this is me apologizing and holding
accountability for myself
if the guy was actually meant to do this
as part of his job i'm sorry
anyway that's all the images that i
think leave some clues towards the film
these actually come from the official
batman calendar which contains several
looks and posters for the film on its
back
the reason i said that the riddler one
might be fan made is because on this
calendar
we can still see that it's black and
white so shout outs to whoever changed
it and if you know the artist just tag
them below
i'll try and add them to the description
i'm so hyped for this film
and it's now less than a year away and i
i really can't wait
the movie will be releasing on the 4th
of march next year
and until then i'll of course be
bringing you all the big updates as they
drop
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts below on what you think about
the images
what plot points do you think they could
be hinting at and yeah just let me know
exactly what your feelings are
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
during the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the pictures
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of vote loki which will be
linked on screen right now the disney
plus show is right around the corner
so i thought we'd do a deep dive on one
of the comics that inspired it
to bring you up to speed with everything
you need to know without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace